my name is Rachel Morrison and I'm the
cinematographer on black house I had to
start by kind of familiarizing myself
with comic books and superhero movies
and Marvel films like that was so not my
wheelhouse but for me it was like a
page-one you know okay first how do you
read what's the language of a comic book
and how do you read it well for one
thing I think part of the reason Ryan
was drawing me is because it wasn't my
wheelhouse and he wanted to do something
it was very different and not you know
sort of straight down the middle
superhero movie so all of his references
for the most part warrant other
superhero films they were films like
samsara and Baraka and looked at planet
Earth but they're all very grounded in
humanity you know and then the story of
family we looked at you know Godfather
and we looked at profit which is kind of
one of our favorite films that we sort
of keep going back to you get to decide
what kind of King you are going to be we
definitely knew which which scenes were
gonna be IMAX so we were composing for
two three nine for the rest of the film
and for the IMAX moments we were closing
for one I know we looked for interesting
battle sequences
you know fight sequences to make the
translation dynamics
I mean the hope is that it puts you even
more in the moment and that it feels
very sort of tactile and visceral and
vertical and you should have immersed in
this experience I think Black Panther
has a little bit of everything
it's you know an action movie but it
comes down to people and places and
humanism and it's not just about good
fighting but it's got it all it's a
battle scene it's really intimate and
human moments I think it really it
touches on a little bit of everything
[Music]